[Musique]
comment ça va me parle pas ça casse mon
rythme on a un souci
il ya du mouvement
on a quinze minutes c'est le moment
envoyez salut les gars
et si je te disais
que je sais ce qui se passe après la
mort
on devient un fantôme
plus de casier judiciaire plus de fêtes
de bureau plus de mariage m mais ce
qu'il ya de mieux quand tu es mort c'est
que tu es libre
plus de politiques plus de diplomatie
personne n'y touche est à moi plus de
comptes à rendre à qui que ce soit
on peut éliminer quelques beau [ __ ]
on est piégé dans l'escalier
j'ai une super mauvaise idée car tu es
mauvaise idée trouve sur une bonne
c'était bien méchant
ils sont tous officiellement mort les
gens se souviendront pas de nous mais
ils se souviendront de cette journée
bonne action
vous êtes qui vous autres
plus personne ils sont peut-être pas
vraiment mort mais ça peut s'arranger
ils ont des avions de chasse du mois se
jouent à ouais tu vois que joueur
désolé d'avoir crié bienvenue à bord du
plus gros aimant du monde tu es un grand
malade
grenade
bon
je n'étais pas sûr que ça marche on
vendra sur sûre à 100% je m'en doutais
seulement mais on est dans tous les bons
coups tout dangereux